und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber hotel
abend heute kann niemand mehr annegret
kramp-karrenbauer als blass und
unauffällig beschreiben
ihr vorstoß gestern hat den
syrien-konflikt auch zu einem thema der
koalition gemacht zu einer
belastungsprobe
deutschland ist herangerückt an den
syrischen bürgerkrieg noch hat die
verteidigungsministerien nicht erklärt
was ihre idee von einer internationalen
sicherheitszone in nordsyrien bedeuten
soll aber eine deutsche militärische
beteiligung wird schon dabei sein sonst
hätte sich die cdu
verteidigungsministerin ja grundlos in
das geschäft des spd außenministers
gedrängt die spd ist so schon sauer
genug obwohl für konkrete kritik
konkrete angriffspunkte fehlen
kramp-karrenbauer blieb vage das muss ja
kein nachteil sein
in der politik andreas kühn as berichtet
berlin hat ein neues heißes thema es
läuft längst auf allen kanälen als die
ministerin an diesem nachmittag die
unions fraktion informiert es läuft
unter sensation es läuft unter
befreiungsschlag aber es läuft nicht gut
also von sms diplomatie halte ich wenig
daraus wird schnell eine es
us-diplomatie dass kramp karrenbauer
über ihre erstaunliche ankündigung beta
diskutiert noch informiert hat dass hat
freund und feind überrumpelt über die
sms an den außenminister lästert halb
berlin
wir stehen für konstruktive gespräche
war noch immer das notwendige zur
verfügung das verfahren selbst weckt
allerdings nicht viel optimismus dass
der rasch ergebnisse sehen werden ich
hoffe wir tauschen uns was kramp
karrenbauer für nordsyrien vorschlägt
ist nicht weniger als ein bruch mit der
deutschen nachkriegspolitik noch nie
ging die bundesrepublik voran in einen
krieg höchstens mit ins kosovo unter
schmerzen
viel lieber hat deutschland nicht
mitgemacht wie im irak oder sich
enthalten sie bei libyen dass
deutschland nun erstmals einen
kriegseinsatz vorschlägt ohne absprache
und ohne details zwingt die spd geradezu
der verteidigungsministerin die
freundschaft zu kündigen
also ich finde schon frau kramp
karrenbauer muss endlich ankommen in
kabinett und sollte durchaus aus den
letzten stunden die ja auch in der
öffentlichen diskussion ihr begegnet
sind ein bisschen lernen
einen versuch ist es allemal wert sagt
kanzlerin merkel über den vorstoß auch
wenn noch viele fragen offen seien
wer mitmacht zum beispiel mit welchem
mandat und vor allem mit wievielen
deutschen soldaten
das ist glaube ich wichtig nein es ist
nicht nur glaube ich es ist wichtig dass
wir da jetzt war so eine initiative
reinkriegen weil einfach nur zuzuschauen
als europäer und abzuwarten was die
anderen machen das ist nun werde ich
keine alternative dass die anderen
europäer jetzt sehr viele fragen haben
berichtet der außenminister seiner
fraktion so offen wie selten schildert
maß zitat gewisse irritationen bei
deutschlands partner
danach treffen sich maas merkel scholz
und kramp karrenbauer
die bundesregierung sucht einen weg eine
schutzzone welche die militärischen
erfolge der türkei dauerhaft
stabilisiert würde diesen namen nicht
verdienen und eine anerkennung und
stärkung des assad regimes durch die
hintertür darf es auch nicht geben
während fdp und afd die idee einer
schutzzone begrüßen lehnt sie die
linkspartei kann
gohrisch ab ein solcher vorschlag muss
man wirklich sagen ist so weit jenseits
der realität und geht wirklich so völlig
an dem vorbei was wir in der region
brauchen dass man nur den kopf schütteln
kann
die spd hat heute gefragt geschimpft und
gespottet
aber nein hat sie noch nicht gesagt der
vorsitzende der spd fraktion im
deutschen bundestag ist ein anerkannter
fachmann für außen und
sicherheitspolitik guten abend herr
mützenich
guten abend der klebe dass sie sich über
den stil von frau kramp karrenbauer
geärgert haben hat man im bericht
gesehen aber wenigstens hat sie eine
initiative gestartet von ihrem
außenminister kamen nichts
vergleichbares
ja ich habe ja gar nicht gegen
initiativen wenn ich weiß um was es geht
aber es ist eine überschrift gebildet
worden und es ist etwas aufgeblasen
worden was schutzzone heißt uns begegnet
dieser begriff schon oft ich mal in die
vereinten nationen
kinder seit jahrzehnten einige können
sich noch an den jugoslawien kriege
erinnern aber auf der anderen seite ist
ja genau die frage was hat sie überhaupt
den kabinett berichtet was möchte sie
hören vom außenminister wie soll er eine
solche initiative vorbereiten
und da kommt gar nichts ich glaube das
richtige gremium wer gewesen am sonntag
im koalitionsausschuss eine stunde
langen diskussion über syrien über die
situation gerade im norden über 200.000
flüchtlinge und ich finde
zumindestens wert stilbildend gewesen
dass am sonntag zumindest mal als idee
zu präsentieren was dahinter steht nun
fragen sie nach dem plan der
verteidigungsminister will hat denn der
außenminister einen plan für eine
deutsche politik in dieser situation
außerhalb von wehklagen und kommentieren
na ja seit mehreren jahren ist die
deutsche außenpolitik bemüht auf der
einen seite und ich finde das ist schon
eine wichtige initiative das leid der
menschen vor ort oder in den
nachbarländern einigermaßen zu lindern
der deutsche bundestag stellt 1,5
milliarden euro an humanitärer hilfe
alleine zur verfügung wir sind der
zweitgrößte geldgeber an die vereinten
nationen aber auf einladung auch der
vereinten nationen haben wir jahrelang
zum beispiel dem ist tura dem
beauftragten des generalsekretärs der
vereinten nationen unterstützt
friedensverhandlungen zu führen das ist
ja auch durchaus an der einen oder
anderen stelle in syrien ein einfluss
der vereinten nationen gewesen aber ich
finde was frau kramp karrenbauer zurzeit
macht ist eine militarisierung der
außenpolitik weil sie unterstellt dass
zum beispiel mit truppen dort eine
andere situation geschaffen wird in
einem fall so ganz ohne truppen in einen
so heißen konflikt einzugreifen wird
auch ein bisschen schwierig seien und
die spd haltung ist erkennbar nichts wie
raus da ihretwegen steht im neuen mandat
der deutschen luft überwachen über
syrien dass sie jetzt aber dringend von
verbündeten abgelöst werden sollte also
lieber raushalten als eingreifen aber
eher kleber das wissen sie doch das war
nicht unsere idee gewesen sondern der
vorgängerin von frau kramp karrenbauer
frau von allein hat dem deutschen
bundestag ein mandat mit der gesamten
zustimmung einschließlich der
bundeskanzlerin vor anderthalb jahren
über sand wo sie gesagt hat es reicht
ein jahr wollen wir noch dort versuchen
mit aufklärungsflügen zu helfen die
ausbildungsmission kann weiterhin
stattfinden das war ja nicht nur
allerdings geht auch der kritische
einsatz ist in syrien und da soll ja
stand weiter aber auch bleiben nein aber
der kleber auch dort fliegt die deutsche
bundeswehr das ist jetzt unterbrochen
worden wegen der komplett
unübersichtlichen situation und ich
finde deutschland muss sich überhaupt
nicht verstecken und ich glaube deutsche
politiker sollten uns auch nicht kleiner
machen als wir sind wir spielen eine
große rolle
aber wir haben auch eine tradition und
die sozialdemokratischen partei hat nun
mal ihre auffassung über eine außen und
sicherheitspolitik und die haben wir
auch in die koalitionsverhandlungen und
jetzt auch in die regierungsarbeit
eingebracht nun entsteht ja eine
situation in der zumindest eine tendenz
besteht dass die cdu in dieser frage
oder die union er für ein eingreifen in
syrien ist und die spd für einen draußen
bleiben das hat 2003 in vergleichbarer
weise ihnen schon mal eine mehrheit
gerettet muss ihnen also eigentlich
politisch ganz gut reinlaufen mir passt
überhaupt nichts rein sondern mich
interessiert was zb
das bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt hat
wenn es über militäreinsätze kommt
deutschlands muss ein völkerrechtliches
und ein verfassungsrechtlich eindeutiges
mandat geschrieben seien vonseiten der
bundesregierung und deswegen brauchen
wir den sicherheitsrat der vereinten
nationen da habe ich von frau kramp
karrenbauer noch gar nicht zugehört ob
sie denn der überzeugung ist dass 15
stimmen im sicherheitsrat zusammen
kommen wozu dann eben auch fünf veto
stimmen gehören
das ist eine komplizierte angelegenheit
die kann man nicht mal einfach mit einer
sms gegenüber dem außenminister
ankündigen
wäre denn eine chance die zustimmung der
spd auch für eine militärische
beteiligung in einer sogenannten
schutzzone zu erreichen wenn die anderen
voraussetzungen gegeben sind oder ist
das ein no go für die spd
es geht nicht sozusagen darum ob logo
sondern es geht um die rahmenbedingungen
und wir beginnen zurzeit eine diskussion
die sich im luftleeren raum auffällt und
ich finde es gehört schon auch zu
unserer verantwortung in der
bundesregierung dazu dass wir auf der
einen seite klar die verankerungen die
wir auf der seite der vereinten nationen
finden und auf der anderen seite auch
der bevölkerung klar zu machen
ein solcher einsatz ist ein großer
einsatz es bei uns geboren wurden in
deutschland das bedeute ich glaube das
feld erzählen sie niemandem etwas neues
ist dieser dieses thema hat dass
genügend sprengkraft um die koalition zu
sprengen wenn es drauf ankommen noch mal
es geht nicht um die koalition sondern
die koalition will arbeiten an ganz
verschiedenen themen natürlich auch an
den außenpolitischen themen aber nochmal
die bundesverteidigungsministerium hat
eine idee geboren die bei den partner
natürlich so ankommt dass wir eine
rahmen nation für diesen einsatz sind
und da wird es mit sicherheit um eine
erkleckliche zahl aus der bundeswehr
gehen und genau das beantwortet sie zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt auch gegenüber der
kabinettsmitglieder und überhaupt nicht
aber viele andere außenpolitische fragen
stehen auch noch im raum ich finde so
kann man in der regierung nicht arbeiten
ein zwischenstand danke für das gespräch
mit dann gehört das interesse und die
einladung
wir haben das gespräch genauso um 20 uhr
geführt termingründe
während deutschland und europa darüber
reden was für pläne sie für syrien
entwickeln könnten
10 putin und erdogan ihren deal durch
jörg brase berichtet sechs stunden lang
hatten sie gerungen dann stand fest die
waffen sollen weitere sechs tage lang
schweigen
der russische und der türkische
präsident einigten sich darauf dass die
von der türkei geforderte
sicherheitszone eingerichtet wird ab
morgen mittag dreiundzwanzigster oktober
werden die terroristen der gpg miliz mit
ihren waffen die zone entlang der grenze
auf einer tiefe von 30 kilometern
verlassen ihre stellungen werden
zerstört nach 150 stunden werden
gemeinsame türkisch russische
patrouillen ihre arbeit aufnehmen in
einem gebiet westlich und östlich
unserer operation friedens quelle
ich bin der meinung dass unsere
entscheidungen sehr wichtig sind
vielleicht sogar entscheidend sie werden
uns helfen die akute situation an der
türkisch syrischen grenze zu löst sie
sind der grund und das ziel der
türkischen militär operation die kämpfer
der kurdischen gpg miliz der syrische
ableger der türkischen
terrororganisation pkk in der stadt kam
ich liebe graben die kämpfer ihre
gefallenen auch von hier sollen sie sich
zurückziehen in den kommenden tagen und
die kurden hier hoffen dass sie dann
nicht türkischen angriffen oder der
rache syrischer truppen ausgeliefert
sind
ja wir haben angst es sei denn die
vereinten nationen oder die russin
helfen uns es muss eine politische
lösung gefunden werden
wir menschen in nordsyrien wollen eine
lösung die von allen syrern betragen
in ihrer not riefen die kurden ihren
verhassten präsidenten um hilfe baschar
al-assad inspiziert von rebellen zurück
eroberte gebiete und er verdammt den
einmarsch türkischer truppen im norden
seines landes für uns ist erdogan
erst hat er unseren weizen dann zusammen
mit den islamisten unser
gestohlen und jetzt steht er unser land
werden sich assad und seine truppen der
vereinbarung zwischen russland und der
türkei beugen us soldaten rücken
richtung norden vor
wir setzen gemeinsam mit ihren
russischen verbündeten eine
luftwaffenbasis vor tagen genutzt von
us-truppen der rückzug der amerikaner
macht russland und das syrische regime
zum gewinner
genauso wie die türkei die bekommt nun
ihre sicherheitszone wird dort syrische
flüchtlinge ansiedeln können
doch bis dahin ist es noch ein langer
weg und die gefahr weiterer kämpfe noch
lange nicht gebannt
die lage ist also nicht einfacher
geworden in den letzten 24 stunden zu
den aktuellen entwicklungen ein
kommentar von wulf schmiese unser neuer
größenwahn
so nannte einst der historiker arnulf
baring deutschlands hang zu moralischer
überheblichkeit den anderen sagen was
sie für den frieden zu tun oder zu
lassen hätten appellieren ammann
vornehmlich die usa auf etlichen
friedensdemo es wurde früher laut
gerufen amigo doch nun geht der ami
wirklich heim präsident trump zieht
soldaten aus syrien zurück wo präsident
obama sie nur widerwillig hin geschickt
hat und deutschland hat erstmal wieder
gemahnt appelliert und war empört nun
die ansage von verteidigungsministerin
kramp karrenbauer dass deutschland mit
frankreich großbritannien sowie russland
und der türkei sich um eine gemeinsame
sicherheitszone in nordsyrien bemühen
solle
klingt ein bisschen irre aber was ist
die alternative zu schauen die weitere
menschen getötet und vertrieben werden
abwarten bis der es wieder stark ist und
die fliegenden zu uns gekommen sind
deutschland ist eigentlich zu groß um
weltpolitik nur von der außenlinie zu
kommentieren das sagte der
sozialdemokrat frank walter steinmeier
als er noch außenminister war
deutschland müsse sich auch
sicherheitspolitisch entschlossener
einbringen fünf jahre ist das her und
jetzt erst scheint kanzlerin merkel das
zu beherzigen
denn sie ist es doch die ihre ministerin
vor geschickt hat
vorsicht mit dem vorwurf es gehe hier
nur darum eine bislang schwache
verteidigungsministerin zu sterben
denn es geht um viel mehr um krieg und
nur wenn es gut läuft um frieden die
ansicht von wulf schmiese chef der
journal redaktion und damit zu deutscher
politik im inneren wo es handfest wird
die deutschen landwirte haben ihrem
ärger über luft gemacht und sich zu
tausenden an bundesweiten
protestaktionen gegen die agrarpolitik
der bundesregierung beteiligt
ihre kritik richtet sich vor allem gegen
immer neue umweltauflagen strengere
dünne verordnungen und die umschichtung
von subventionen das sogenannte agrar
partie gefährde die existenz vieler
bäuerlicher familienbetriebe
landwirtschaftsministerin klöckner ging
auf die kritik ein und sicherte den
bauern unterstützung bei den
veränderungen zu
der vorschlag der bundesbank in den
nächsten jahrzehnten das rentenalter auf
fast 70 anzuheben hat eine kontroverse
ausgelöst
deutliche kritik kommt von den
gewerkschaften bereits die rente mit 67
sei ein fehler
die viele ältere arbeitnehmer würden oft
arbeitslos oder chronisch krank gerieten
in altersarmut positiv reagieren
arbeitgeberverbände fdp und teile der
cdu die lebenserwartung steige und dürfe
nicht nur einen längeren ruhestand
bedeuten die durch umlagenfinanzierte
renten stoße bald an ihre grenzen
rund sechs wochen nach seiner wahl zum
ortsvorsteher im hessischen altenstadt
waldsiedlung ist der npd-politiker jaxx
wieder abgesetzt worden
der ortsbeirat stimmte am abend für die
abberufung youngs kündigte bereits
juristische schritte an
seine wahl hatte anfang september
bundesweit empörung ausgelöst
er war mit stimmen von cdu spd und fdp
ins amt gekommen
bei der parlamentswahl in kanada sind
die liberalen um premierminister trikot
erneut stärkste kraft geworden
allerdings haben sie ihre absolute
mehrheit
eingebüßt rudow muss nun eine
minderheitsregierung bilden und ist auf
die unterstützung kleinerer parteien
angewiesen
der 47-jährige im wahlkampf von
skandalen belastet erklärte er habe die
enttäuschung seiner kritiker vernommen
und werde ihre forderungen ernst nehmen
so wolle er den kampf gegen waffengewalt
und gegen den klimawandel fortsetzen
heute hätte wieder mal ein schicksalstag
in sachen boris johnson und seinem braig
cit werden können aber es wurde keiner
für ein schicksalstag ist das ergebnis
zu verbrauchen
obwohl es für johnson und sein blick
sieht erstmal gut zu laufen schien die
erstaunliche nachricht zu beginn die
regierung johnson hat tatsächlich eine
wichtige abstimmung siegreich durchs
parlament gebracht nach vielen
vergeblichen anrufen
johnstons gesetzespaket zum eu-austritt
wurde heute mit 20 stimmen mehrheit
angenommen jahrhundert in ein finale im
prinzip allerdings nur rechtskräftig
kann das erst werden wenn alle
gesetzgebungs stufen durchlaufen sind
das sieht ja der änderungsantrag vom
vergangenen samstag zuvor
die frage war nun wie schnell kann so
etwas geschehen die regierung wollte die
entscheidung in nur drei tagen
durchpeitschen
ich beantrage hiermit diese
gesetzesvorlage vor zu bringen damit sie
in der besten tradition dieses hauses
einer genauen prüfung unterzogen werden
kann
die gute alte tradition der genauen
überprüfung über 100 seiten hat das
dokument jemand hat mal nachgerechnet
dass das gesetz zum schutz wilder tiere
in zirkussen länger debattiert wurde
entsprechend skeptisch ist die
opposition meine frau hat gesagt dass
sie und ich mehr zeit dafür aufwenden
ein sofa aus zu suchen als wir hier für
die debatte über dieses wichtige
dokument doch die praxis müdigkeit ist
allerorten zu spüren im parlament im
land und auch bei der eu die ja noch
über eine praxis fristverlängerung
entscheiden muss dies die worte jean
claude junckers bei seiner abschiedsrede
im eu parlament
es schmerzt und ich so viel zeit mit der
exit verbracht haben zu müssen obwohl
ich doch eigentlich nur daran hätte
denken sollen wie man diese union
verbessern kann so viel zeit und
energieverschwendung dann aber wie
gewohnt eine niederlage für johnson der
strenge zeitplan wurde vom parlament
abgelehnt
was jetzt austritt fristverlängerung
oder vielleicht bald neuwahlen oder
beides nach einem langen tag im
parlament sind großbritannien und der
rest europas wieder so schlau wie zuvor
wir suchen rat bei unseren
korrespondenten in straßburg und in
london fangen wir mal ob der handlung
heute an diana wenn wir es richtig
verstanden haben dann kriegt boris
johnson jedenfalls nicht bis zum 31.10
seinen deal durch und was macht er jetzt
er trotzt und droht würde ich sagen er
hat kurz nach der abstimmung gleich
gesagt er werde jetzt die notfallpläne
für den ksb exit erstmal aufrüsten denn
wenn großbritannien nicht mehr mit den
austreten kann weil der zeitplan nicht
mehr klappt dann werde es das jetzt eben
ohne tun das lässt allerdings außer acht
dass er selbst am samstag einen brief
abgeschickt hat diktiert vom parlament
mit der bitte um eine verlängerung bis
zum 31
januar die eu hat darüber noch nicht
entschieden und er hat gesagt er wird
druck auf brüssel ausüben dass sie diese
verschiebung auch nicht genehmigen denn
er der diesen austritt am 31.10 so oft
versprochen hat möchte dass er
stattfindet dann wenn nötig auch ohne
dir das heißt dann steht jetzt sozusagen
die eu an
vor der wahl ob sie den einen johnson
der die verlängerung beantragt hat
bevorzugen oder den anderen johnson der
sie hat nicht haben will
ich glaube die wenn die eu für diese
arbeit steht ist die entscheidung
ziemlich klar sie bevorzugen natürlich
den johnston der die verlängerung
beantragt hat und eu-diplomaten wiesen
heute abend darauf hin dass der antrag
ja längst vorliegt seit samstagabend mit
einer verlängerung einer verschiebung um
drei monate
und dass sich schon morgen nach dem
jetzt auch der eu seite klar geworden
ist dass offenbar der austrittstermin 31
oktober nicht zu halten ist dass sich
schon morgen die eu botschafter der 27
mitgliedsländer treffen werden um über
diesen antrag zu beraten und man muss
kein prophet sein um davon ausgehen zu
können das diese verlängerung bewilligt
wird die eu seite will boris johnson
damit etwas zeit geben sich mit seiner
parlament weiter auseinander zu setzen
und vielleicht eben doch nach diesem
teilerfolg heute abend eine zustimmung
zu dem deal zu bekommen und dann wird
man weitersehen
der appetit auf einen sondergipfel der
staats und regierungschefs ist nicht
sehr groß auch dass ein teil der praxis
müdigkeit und eins ist klar
donald tusk der rat chef hat es heute
hier im europaparlament noch mal in alle
mikrofone und kameras gesagt wenn die eu
die bahn hat ist ihre wahl nicht das
szenario eines ungeordneten eines chaos
praxis das heißt also er bekommt aus
brüssel boris johnson bekommt aus
brüssel die verlängerung ob er sie haben
will oder nicht damit ist sein
deadline 31 oktober tot bastian werde
jetzt versuchen soweit man das
abschätzen kann
ja ich denke damit rechnet er natürlich
auch aber es passt natürlich wieder in
das bild das er von sich selber zeichnen
möchte dass er alles wirklich alles
versucht für den bhc rexit am 31 oktober
er hat jetzt zwei weitere möglichkeit
mehr könnte die angesagt auf das
parlament zugehen und das tun was die
parlamentarier heute eigentlich
signalisiert haben über diesen deal dem
sie grundsätzlich erstmal zugestimmt
haben weiter mit ihnen diskutieren er
weiß natürlich dass dann viele einwände
kommen eventuell änderungsanträge die zb
ein zweites referendum fordern oder eine
doch nähere anbindung als seien dies
momentan vorsieht dann müsste er
kompromisse machen
oder aber und seine reaktion heute abend
legt das durchaus da er versteigt sich
auf die rolle als der unbefleckte
kämpfer für den bhc rexit und versucht
in dieser rolle in neuwahlen zu gehen
und der bevölkerung zu signalisieren ich
wurde aufgehalten und gebremst ich habe
alles versucht aber ich habe keine
kompromisse geschlossen die euren dreck
cit verraten hätten das problem hier ist
im britischen recht brauche dafür eine
zweidrittel mehrheit des parlaments die
hat er natürlich nicht labour liegt in
den umfragen hinten und hat eigentlich
keine rechte lust auf neuwahlen momentan
allerdings steigt natürlich auch der
druck auf die opposition jetzt etwa
wirklich etwas zu bewegen anstatt immer
nur zu bremsen
insofern gehe ich davon aus dass wir
relativ bald neuwahlen haben wir werden
sehen
danke an sie beide und hier geht es
weiter mit nachrichten aus der
wirtschaft in deutschland
das wirtschafts thema des tages lieferte
heute der berliner senat mit seinem
beschluss für einen mieten deckel
bundesweit einmalig und bundesweit
heftig diskutiert wird diese
entscheidung des rot rot grünen senats
valerie haller gegen die nicht nur die
wohnungswirtschaft sturm läuft genau
auch bundesbauminister seehofer zum
beispiel er sagt mehr bauland mehr
bautätigkeit seien nötig der mieten
deckel würde investoren abschrecken und
ähnlich argumentiert auch die
immobilienwirtschaft sie befürchtet dass
in berlin künftig weniger wohnungen
gebaut oder modernisiert werden der
mieterverein hingegen spricht von einer
historischen chance bezahlbare mieten
für viele zu sichern
der mieten deckel gilt nicht für
neubauten unterm strich aber für einen
großteil des berliner wohnungsmarkt
betroffen sind eineinhalb millionen
wohnungen für diese werden mieten fünf
jahre lang eingefroren stichtag für die
miethöhe ist rückwirkend der achtzehnte
juni dieses jahres
außerdem gibt es obergrenzen bei
wiedervermietung maximal neun euro 80
pro quadratmeter
mieter sollen künftig ihre miete auch
kappen können wer mehr als 20 prozent
über der obergrenze liegt kann einen
entsprechenden antrag stellen
mieterhöhungen darf es frühestens in
drei jahren geben um 1,3 prozent als
inflationsausgleich
anfang nächsten jahres soll das gesetz
in kraft treten
die entscheidende frage ist ob das land
berlin ein solches gesetz überhaupt
beschließen darf in den kommenden jahren
dürften sich also richter mit dem mieten
decke beschäftigen und die mieter in
berlin wissen womöglich erst zum schluss
ob sie später vielleicht sogar miete
nachzahlen müssen
vielen dank valerie für diese
einschätzung
eine meldung vom fußball in der
champions league hat bayer leverkusen
auch sein drittes gruppenspiel verloren
atletico madrid gewann 1 0
mit dieser dritten niederlage in der
gruppenphase steht bayer leverkusen in
der königsklasse vor dem aus der schaden
durch wirtschaftskriminalität geht laut
bundeskriminalamt insgesamt zurück
zunehmend aber verüben die täter ihre
betrügereien im internet etwa mit seriös
wirkenden webseiten oder über die
sogenannten sozialen medien
insgesamt schätzt das bka hat
wirtschaftskriminalität im vergangenen
jahr einen schaden von 3,4 milliarden
euro verursacht in fast 6.500 fällen
wurde das internet für die tat genutzt
hier gab es ein plus von 27 prozent im
vergleich zum vorjahr die rettung der
großvater des mannes der heute den
chrysanthemen ton von japan bestieg war
für sein volk noch ein gottkönig an
direkt danach nach war der sonnengöttin
kein untertan durfte ihn auch nur
erblicken und selbst fotos von ihm waren
heilige gegenstände das alles versank in
hiroshima nagasaki dem grausamen ende
des zweiten weltkriegs der auch im namen
des kaisers geführt worden war
general mcarthur der befehlshaber des
pazifik krieges entschloss sich dem
geschlagenen feind seinen kaiser zu
lassen damit der ruhe stiften kann
aber er ließ ihn aller macht und
göttlichkeit entkleiden und nun heute
erhob sich seinen enkel naruhito ein
mensch in aller form zum kaiser
stephanie schöneborn berichtet über ein
einzigartiges ritual still und würde
voll vor 2000 gästen verkündet der 126
kaiser japan seine inthronisierung ein
ritual wie aus einer anderen welt
inmitten eines modernen japan
ich schwöre hiermit das sich gemäß der
verfassung handeln und meine pflichten
als symbol des staates und der einheit
des volkes von japan erfüllen werde
während ich stets wo das glück des
volkes und den weltfrieden beete und
immer dem volk am frühen morgen beginnt
die zeremonie kaiser nero ii total den
gottheiten mit dass er seine
regentschaft verkünden wird naruto ist
der erste kaiser japans dem ausland
studiert hat gilt als moderne seine frau
masako die fünf sprachen spricht
diplomatin ist folgt ihm befohlenen
abstand nach dem strengen hofprotokoll
aus längst vergangenen zeiten
beide sind in einer generation
aufgewachsen die von einer demokratie
geprägtes eine generation in der man
viel diskutiert und sich selbst
verwirklicht deswegen wird der neue
kaiser nicht nur symbolische dinge
vornehmen wie beten oder den menschen
beistehen
sie werden vermutlich viel stärker etwas
konkretes etwas für sie typisches
während der regentschaft umsetzen wollen
die regentschaft von kaiser mariotto
trägt die devise raver was so viel heißt
wie schöne harmonie wählen oder eine
eigene politische meinung haben darf das
kaiserpaar laut protokoll nicht
und die frage nach modernisierung der
monarchie löst bei anhängern
ihr erstaunen aus nein der kaiser ist
das symbol japans da sollte nichts
modernisiert werden kaiser marino wird
wie die tradition es will ab jetzt japan
dem volk und die protokoll dienen
regierungschef beruf zum schluss des
rituals
lang lebe der kaiser schon seltsam
japans kaiser ein mann der vor allem
würde ausstrahlen soll und dem die
eigene verfassung die menschenwürde
nimmt seine frau und er sind die
einzigen japaner die keine meinung
äußern
am besten keine meinung haben dürfen zu
den freiheiten einfacher menschen 37
grad begleitet drei die sich dem
konsumterror entziehen in einem winzigen
hütchen in bayern oder mitten im
odenwald ein jahr lang haben die
reporterinnen sie begleitet ein blick in
ein anderes leben
[Musik]
mit einem liebe zuschauer ist bleibt bei
sonne und nebel und in der sonne da wird
es richtig war bei uns in mitteleuropa
um die 20 grad noch wärmer sommerliche
werte haben wir östlich von uns hier
über den balkan am mittelmeer 25 grad
und ganz anders am westlichen mittelmeer
weiterhin dort in spanien vor einige
recht kühl
da haben wir immer noch den regen ein
neues regengebiet wird jetzt heute nacht
hier sehen sie spanien hier nordafrika
von algerien richtung ibiza mallorca
zieht und dann nochmal für kräftigen
regen sorgen
das ganze zieht dann morgen weiter
erreicht auch den süden von frankreich
zum teil unwetterartige regenmengen die
darunter kommen werden bei uns sind wir
davon verschont es gibt dicken nebel
heute nacht wieder an der donau bodensee
am rhein aber auch in norddeutschlands
ganzen hebel geben und dazu sind es
morgen für sechs bis zehn grad tagsüber
wird es in norddeutschland doch doch ein
bisschen wolkiger seien über schleswig
holstein ziehen immer wieder dichte
wolken hinweg bei diesem schwachen
südwind aber sonst im landesinneren wird
es recht freundlich mit sonne und wolken
das gilt dann auch für die südhälfte
deutschlands aber da haben wir eben
nebel und hochnebel weiterhin von der
donau bis nach münchen
vielleicht auch hier am main mal oder am
frühen morgenstunden vor allen dingen
auch am oberrhein
es wird leider dazu nur dieser schwache
nordostwind so dass es lange zeit
braucht bis die daneben sich auflöst die
temperaturen steigen außerhalb des
nebels noch ein bisschen an 17 bis 20
grad mit föhn mit 23 und nur an den
küsten bleibt es ein bisschen frischer
der donnerstag wird nochmal ganz ähnlich
dann am freitag wird es wolkiger von
norden her und etwas kühler und samstag
im norden regen und dazu dann auch einen
kräftigen wittich wünschen noch einen
schönen abend und machen sie es gut